welcome to this video a new part of the
set chest giant serious presenting great
games from the past games that should
have instructive value but also should
simply be there to to enjoy and yeah a
little bit of entertainment value and
watching great games
yeah let's um get oops right into the
thick of it this is a game between bent
Larsen and Tigran Petrosian this was
played in 1966 1966 um let me think
about this yes
Petrosian at the time the world champion
Larsen um
in the late 60s was competing with Bobby
Fischer's being the best player of the
Western Hemisphere it did hacked wasn't
so clear only in the 1970s when Fisher
started his famous run for the World
Championship it wasn't that clear really
that Fischer was with any better than
Larsen both had excellent results and
regularly competed for first prizes in
in tournaments it was in fact a total
sensation that Fischer managed to beat
Larsen six six zero in 1971 I think it
was um let's look at this game from
nineteen sixty six thousand Petrosian
and also when we say okay it wasn't
clear was better we also need to take
into account that they didn't have any
rating system back then they just you
could only compare results let's say but
he couldn't compare ratings let's see
what happened here Larsen Petrosian
played in Santa Monica in 1966 here we
have an open Sicilian and Petrosian
place here with g6 the accelerated
dragon and we get the maroc see point
with c4
here black has some white a white choice
of of lines that he that he can play
nowadays the most popular line here's
some d6 maybe back then it also was the
most popular line d6 there should be two
castles castles and then the capture
here and Bishop d7 or Bishop d7 before
capturing this kind of position
Petrosian played a different line
he went from Knight to g4 yeah quite a
funny-looking move and starting some
some tactics yeah black is some
threatening to take III white must take
this night there is no choice and now
like takes on default yeah here there is
the threat of Knight see to check and
also the threat that this D pawn might
move white really has nothing else he
must retreat back to d1 and yeah now the
knight on d4 is detected yeah black now
has three options he can play in 96 as
in the game can retreat to c6 or play e5
yeah the move from knight c6 is
definitely possible it just gets to the
typical maroc see structure with white
having the space advantage also it is
very well known that exchanging one pair
of Knights is quite okay for black so
this is definitely a playable variation
whatever white definitely enjoys a
slight edge due to his space he thought
is a very sharp option white he has
possibilities like night b5 after which
black castles very sharp stuff back then
this wasn't really explored and there's
96 this was played by Petrosian it's
quite funny that this also was a
favorite of Ben blossom somewhat later
he also played this is this line at the
time but later
played 96 and quite a number of times
okay
why does playing Queen d2 and now
Pedroza plays d6 this is the
conservative move Queen a five and some
what later made this variation an
interesting battleground the ideas that
after Luke c1 b6 you should be - Bishop
e7 f3 black plays g5 looks kinda crazy
but it's very interesting g5 prepares a
centralization of this Bishop and their
very unique position that can only arise
exactly from this opening and this line
the very very strange situation white
however is believed to be better him
nowadays I mean back then it wasn't
clear d6 as mentioned a bit more
conservative Petrosian is not the kind
of guy place stuff like g5 so Bishop e2
Bishop d7 they both cancelled laza now
played rook a to d1 this is definitely a
good move alternatively I'd like to
suggest before notice also as possible
what black wants to do here is he needs
to improve this night only six the night
only six really only has one a decent
square that's c5 black wants to get in
night to c5 a5 Bishop C 6 that says set
up that has been proved to be very
resilient and the problem is he wants to
get it in but it's not so easy to do
after 81 black here faces the idea of c5
if black plays sort of nothing then c5
is a very very interesting option using
this default pressure
it's also why Petrosian is reacting to
that you played the Bishop c6 I think
here lozen definitely played a good move
95 is not a mistake centralizing the
night but I think here
he should have probably already taken
the chance to play em to play before
gaining this this big space on them on
the Queen side of course you can argue
that black to take but that's not really
the case if we look at this Bishop h6 is
a very very problematic for black after
you create the move Bishop g4 is
absolutely deadly we threatened to take
him and made on g7 and after f5 look
everyone the threat of rook takes e4 as
killing black completely now this is
just complete win so he could have
played before
technically justified and this is all
about the night on e6 which is a very
unlucky piece
yeah 95 was played and here Petrosian
played the lose rook e8 and this move is
a bit mysterious I understand that black
wants to protect a 7 so that maybe he
can move the Queen away sometime and
sometimes also the rope here is a little
bit better than FFF 8 they don't f8 but
here he had a chance and the chance he
definitely should should have taken you
should have played Knight to c5 this is
much better
in comparison the reason is that black
is winning a temple now with the tech on
the e4 pawn yeah there's F 3 and then a
5 is the the key move that black needs
to get in now before is prevented and he
has established this knight on c5 yeah
it still stays the maroc C blind and I'm
slightly biased there because it's one
of those opening were openings where
with white 1/2 like
90% score and never lost a game in an
tournament chess I always feel that what
should be should be very comfortable but
this is the kind of setup that proves to
be very tough to break down with a 5 in
and what year has not does not have much
of an alternative if he plays Queen c2
we come to an interesting situation here
black can even play the move a5 very
interesting spot the key point is that
white now after Bishop takes D takes
Knight FCS can win the Queen but if you
look at this position Bishop f6 rook e8
ever takes d8 this is a position where
black has one bishop and the rook for
the Queen but nevertheless has an
excellent compensation black here enjoys
permanent control over the default
Square and simply has more ideas than
white has White has a very bad Bishop
only two and not one clear plan how to
proceed while black can try to play on
the default a4 rook a 6v6 all kinds of
ideas nowadays computers understand that
black has a compensation but this is the
type of position where maybe a computer
will easily yeah who would rights
position together but in a practical
game I think black is very comfortable
he just says is easier to play
Petrossian made a mistake here played
rook e8 and this is missing this Knight
c5 chance Larsson now went with m4a
goodness gaining space before was a very
good alternative again Knight c7 was
played and now f5 this is very strong
very powerful chess
white is taking lots of space and the
Black Knight cannot return anymore to e6
f5 looks in some way
dubious maybe to some because it gives
up control over the e5 square you know
this is also why a move like that should
be yeah considered very carefully you
cannot really put the pawn pawn back to
f4 and the e5 square can be tricky
however the piece that really wants to
be there is a knight and the Black
Knight is not coming there
not ever from c7 this is very difficult
to establish or to try from from c7
patrols are now played Knight a six
which ultimately it's not really great
well let's say it's not improving his
position it is however very difficult
here to give him some advice probably
relatively speaking the capture was best
ET of course it takes two yeah
white wants to have this pressure on the
e-file maybe coming C takes D s just
very lame Bishop d7 and Bishop b3 this
kind of position here f4 f5 is a useful
advance and this might easily be the
prelude to a very dangerous inside
attack if we imagine something like
Bishop to h6
rook f3 rook f1 rook h3 White has space
advantage on the Kings side and will use
the space advantage to build it's built
is a tech based on that like has some
very hard time to defend this position
but it was probably better than the game
he went to a6 and their ideas not
putting it on the edge of the board but
go here here oops not there let's try
this again
- II five ultimately so Petrosian has a
clear defensive idea but it is
ultimately not working his problem
really was that he missed the chance to
play Knight c5 this was a big error
yeah here is white smooth what should he
play Larsen smooth is is very
interesting and original and it is
however in some way great that he played
it because without the move we would
have would gather the the the final the
end of the game which is super
spectacular wouldn't be a wouldn't be on
the board but objectively speaking his
next move is a mistake
nas not played Bishop to g4 yeah and and
somewhat mysterious moves one ideas that
white wants to capture on on g6 and on F
takes G six he wants Bishop e6 check
this is the the idea and after F takes G
six H takes G six the idea was to go
Queen f2 to H four with the tempo we
would see this in the game the ideas are
of the move arm are pretty much clear
when we look at this look at this later
however it turns out that black has
probably decent chances to defend not
easy to defend but he has chances to do
so better was before again absolutely
making sure that this night is not
coming to c5 and just keeping it out of
play after before White's position
becomes overwhelming I guess what black
must do is Knight c7 back it looks
really ugly but probably he needs to do
that there are other things that
directly need to to disaster this move
for example if you want to try this to
get to e5 white is pushing b5 and this
for example is an immediate killed b7
hangs and f7 hangs you know + c5 just
far too much too much your Bishop d7
alternatively there is Bishop d4 and
this intends to push f6
now it's it's absolutely not defensible
something like this for example might
look like it did should hold but there
is also c5 with Bishop c4 coming CD 6
coming it's falling apart
those pieces don't play before was a
very strong move but Bishop g4 was also
interesting very original solution
typically a bit typical of Larsen style
he very often came up with solution that
nobody else really could think of but
they were very often excellent choices
yeah night c5 this is the right move and
now captured on g6 this was the idea
takes Queen f2 all this is according to
plan and all based on concrete lines
yeah f7 hangs there's not much else
black must play look back to evade and
here lovin comes up with with a great
concept really he had some some simple
choices here let's look at some the
first moves that maybe comes to mind is
to take just grab him and a look from
here Wyatt here can think again
yeah of this this idea winning the Queen
yeah Mitch needs to be checked I mean we
win we win the Queen but after Bishop
takes rook takes rook takes white cannot
take on c5 as Bishop deform wins the
Queen so we must play a queen walking
movement after that black is easily
occupying the d4 square and has
fantastic play this is just better for
black yeah rook and Bishop I mean
perfectly harmonized here c6 f 6 it's a
totally stable position and black has
has a great game here and it's it's in
addition much easier to play it's not
just object objectively good but also
much easier to play as
your pieces coordinate well so the Queen
Wynn is absolutely unacceptable for
white what is the most obvious move him
Queen h4 I guess it's the most obvious
after Queen age for black whoever has a
defense he can take on d5 and now after
Luke takes which is the move why
probably wants to play being the most
dynamic black has two moves is six and
suddenly the whole game turns into
blacks favor
the Queen here are looking Queens
looking at each other so h4 is the check
and the rook is attacked white really
has nothing better than to trade Queens
and after rook retreat you even drop the
pawn so a very disappointing result from
White Queen h4 is simply not so great
and so what did last do you play the
great movie that a5 this is a mysterious
looking move what is the idea of it yeah
it's it's quite it's quite remarkable
black takes only five with the bishop
yeah
and Queen h4 almost the same thing the
difference is that there is no e4 pawn
anymore and the bishop is on d5
the big difference is that after Bishop
takes d5 which was played and should be
played rook takes d5 now here the mooks
is six is a different story if black now
plays is six then white has the
additional idea after this this to play
rook takes d5 and this is ye 5 Bishop
takes d5 was inserted to get the Bishop
to e5 and get this this interesting
transformation in yeah but how is this
to be assessed I think that black is in
fact quite okay here it's an interesting
position that black could have played
look at this takes bishop takes
probably route c8 activating the rook
and now white yeah
no white should drop back Bishop takes
maybe Bishop to the one getting over to
b3 this is a very interesting position
White has two bishops against Luke and
two pawns but black it's a pretty
compact he does not have very
substantial pawn weaknesses and the rook
some are positioned on open files hmm
maybe it is a bit better for white if
anybody maybe white but it is not not
not clear at all
so this was playable for black
definitely but Georgian however chose to
move Knight to e6 getting this Knight
back into the defense it seems that this
move was also came but it means to
really play a tightrope walking a
tightrope defense IAM ecigs was simpler
as it simply stops the direct attack and
now this is exactly what Lawson is going
for just yeah
checkmate mode rook f3 to h3 Queen f7
mate crude but very very dangerous yeah
what should black do now how to defend
very em very tough table like this
exactly is the key position the move
that Petrosian now is playing is is
losing the game but very very difficult
to see I mean he was a fantastic player
so it's not like he blundered here some
some easy stuff black only has one
defense really it's just one move that
keeps the position together and it
requires extreme accuracy even
afterwards the move is f5 it looks it
looks like it's totally weakening flexor
blacks game but what he needs to do is
he definitely needs
it's an additional square for the King
if you look at this for a while with the
computer you don't come to a totally
clear conclusion but it seems that black
is at least holding on and shouldn't
shouldn't lose some to to a mate or
something let's have a look Ruka h3 this
must be the critical threatening the
direct mate black now can play two moves
Knight g7 or King F Sam they by the way
can transpose King of 7 for example what
can Y do here at first you think that
Bishop takes a five might be strong
let's look at this it's quite a funny
line and Bishop takes a five G takes
Queen is five
it looks totally devastating at first
King f6 the only move that is not losing
immediately this is of course Jack
checkmate a major you absolutely must go
oops
to f6 this looks like black should be
mated but it's not that's nothing
there's nothing apparent how this should
work
there's of concern many Perpetual checks
for white but there is no no way to a
checkmate g4 looks very dangerous
intending to play g5 or Queen takes f5
but got dangerous it might look but 97
is somehow saving the day it's really a
remarkable remarkable position the the
best for white is to give the check here
and check and get in here why does the
piece down yeah don't ever forget that
Bishop f6 and now the capture the king
is just about to escape on is he just
about exclaiming on d7
Bishop f6 rook f6 Queen g7 and now Queen
g8 and this is the key move that that
saves black at the end we get the
Queen's off and okay we have a situation
where black is a pawn down but he has
good chances of getting a pawn back yeah
f5 see for those pawns can easily get
lost here wide the snuffin does not have
anything special note that here the king
is well placed on the 7 actually joining
the action a very long line and
exceptionally difficult to calculate
King f7 is is one possibility by the way
after King of seven white of course does
not need to take 105 it's a very
interesting line but there is also check
queen h7 this is a position that we will
would seem soon after this move this is
the alternative to king of 7 here white
can give the check I can play em Bishop
e3 Bishop f3 was was an interesting
alternative there j7 king f7 route gauge
6 is another interesting way here to to
try to try to mate black but after the
capture Queen GC CAC and King g8 it
turns out that there is not much better
than this is perpetual it is just a draw
White has no way to to further improve
his attack information route gauge 7
queenie 8 it's a pretty simple
refutation
so after night g7 there's probably
Bishop f3 that needs to be played after
a bishop f3 black cam should probably
continue
with with king f7 there are there are
alternatives but this is probably the
best king f7 and now it can it can
continue root b 5 and now b 6
yeah funny like is some allowing this
capture but if we look at this if white
is taking the exchange after Queen takes
it's clear that the the big attack now
has been defused
yeah there is no mating attack anymore
and black has a pawn for the exchange
something that Petrosian of course was
very much used to is was the master of
the the exchange sacrifice um y term can
play for an advantage here but it's not
not a decisive decisive thing it's still
a fight this is what black absolutely
needed to do he needed to play f5 in
order to defend na Petrosian played
Bishop f6 and it's not like it's
immediately apparent where this should
be a mistake
but we would see that black in fact now
is beyond saving
Queen h6 was played and now white just
threatens Bishop takes c6 and Queen
takes g6 yeah the very idea of Bishop g4
was to control those squares and get
this attack attacking ideas going black
really it has a hard time to defend
against and also there is just rook h3
threat and of course so black cannot
play moves like this year after Queen
after Ruka sri it's just going to be
check check
checkmate quick maid coming so we're
very very dangerous position yeah
Petrosian played Bishop g7 he was
absolutely relying on the smooth however
now we come to to the exact position
that is always shown in in books when
when
scam when this game is displayed right
now as a fantastic move maybe you can
you can think of it yourself I'm going
to show it now right now played the
greatness community X g6 for Queen
sacrifice that's very very nice now what
happens if black captures he didn't
capture but what happens if he does
Bishop takes c6 yeah now black really is
in big trouble if he moves the King
there is just this chat coming you know
this is threatening Bishop takes f8 mate
yeah great attack information with
bishops and rook fantastic so he cannot
even just move the King you must play
rook f7 and here Y term can take
hatcheck yeah going to the H file is the
same thing Ruka three check and this
here is a decisive attack black has
absolutely no defense
note that the Queen also has no square
to go to you know something like this
for example is answered by a check check
check and wins yeah very nice
this is just an overwhelming attack
Petrosian tried something to try
something funny he played the desperado
Knight f4 it's almost the same thing now
rook takes now he took the crack and the
check so we have almost the same
position just the rook being on air for
instead over three yeah he played rook
f7 it's the same thing if he would will
play this check it's the killer
yeah it's no difference of the root
being on edge form instead of being on
h3
he went through gives him
yeah and here allows and in fact had a
choice Bishop takes f7 was also winning
but he captured with the rook this is
also very convincing
yeah here the idea is to play a check
here and go over to the edge file
Petrosian tried Group H King h8 and yeah
it's too late for any advice I mean if
he plays let's say the Queen move there
is really not much then okay there's a
c7 is very simple
yeah where should you go there is really
nothing maybe here and then we have the
Shannon idea check and again we have the
crossfire mate yeah he went to age eight
and now last finds very nice winning
maneuver route to g5 the ideas group G 3
H 3 yeah
b5 played really it does not matter it's
always the same and now Ruby g3
intending rook h3 and it's over yeah
something like let's say the Queen Queen
move somewhere if we have this check
check check
checkmate and emit very nice rooks and
bishops are killing the black king yeah
this is one of London's most famous
games deservedly so it's a very very
nice finish to the game with Queen takes
g6 fantastic fantastic move to to get in
yeah and we see that it was due to
Bishop f6 that that allowed the whole
thing however we shouldn't underestimate
the big pressure that black was on I
mean pieces I involved in the attack
and even for defense defense wizards
like Petrosian the the the task was too
difficult to solve he didn't find the
only way to defend the position so a
very nice game by an awesome yeah I hope
you enjoyed this one of the most famous
game of the the great Danish Grandmaster
yeah thanks for watching and I'll be
back soon with new episodes of the
series bye